like they used a thumbnail that i looked
stupid or a title that made me sound
like an idiot and i was like ben i don't
like that he goes oh
you thought that selling out to the
algorithm was gonna feel good
[Music]
all right
we're live let's do this um you want to
get right into twitter no
yeah let's get into twitter wait let me
tell you something really quick
i just remembered i was gonna tell you
about this i did a body fat scan the
other day yesterday
okay
bad news for all of us man
why what happened i was 15 percent
why is that for all of us because if
you're 50 if i'm 15
like yeah if i'm 15
like that sucks for everyone else i felt
like i was like 11.
that's just because people [__] like
people who are like i'm six percent body
fat and then like doctors are like no
you you are not six percent body fat you
would be like you know
sick if you were 66 body fat that's just
not the case so i think like what people
say is six to eight percent body fat is
actually 12 to 15 or like 12 to 14 or
something like that and uh so i think 15
is great i was 26 last time i did a dexa
scan 2627 something like that
and my goal was
actually i don't even remember what it
was i think maybe my goal was to get
under 25 i was 28 or something like that
i was amazed at how high i do it every
three months that's good i i was made
amazed at how how high mine was it uh
because like i don't feel like
completely ripped but i feel like
fit like i don't have a stomach anymore
and i and it was still 15. i was shocked
we've all seen the picture if you go to
my twitter we've all seen the picture
you're ripped you're actually the
perfect amount of ripped uh because you
know there's an obnoxious ripped where
if you look like oh man this guy's just
he's just it's like a girl who's like uh
got like hair extensions eyelash
extensions uh nail extensions and like
tons of makeup caked on it's like oh
they're sort of trying too hard and it's
like a high maintenance person that i
don't really want like i don't really
want to go out to dinner with you
because you're just gonna order like
broccoli and you know like raw chicken
or whatever so you know you're like the
right amount where it's like oh man he
might live an active lifestyle like
maybe he surfs and like maybe that's why
uh it doesn't look like someone who is
like you know jim bro who just lives in
the gym four hours a day and everything
centers around that in their life well
the point is is that it just shocked me
at 15 but i just wanted to
to let you know that that happened uh
let's talk about all right so we're
gonna talk about you're officially
canceled as a fitness influencer you
can't be a fitness influencer i know 12
is okay anything above 12 i i got to get
my [__] together you could do you could
just do it as the start of your fitness
journey
is this this am i i'm still a before i
feel like now you're before i feel like
i've been a before picture for the past
five years i'm still at before [__]
damn we already said there's before
before i'm a before before
and then there's a before you're a
before now no i'm just kidding you're
more like an after uh i'm now a before
but i wasn't before before
your system you just gotta know the
ranking system it's not about body fat
percentage um all right let's get into
it all right so we're gonna what's the
what's the topic of what's the the title
of this segment
the title of the segment is
sam and sean cross 1 million downloads a
month for the podcast they get
intoxicated by the growth we're on pace
for 1.3 right now
smashing old record highs of 900 000 and
with this intoxicating growth they say
we're gonna [__] out double down and
we're gonna make a list and so we're
gonna do list episodes that's what's
actually happening here now what list
did we decide to start with well
we didn't go ultra tantalizing ultra
drama filled list to begin with we're
going with
our favorite twitter follow so i think
we're going to have 12
is it 12 total so our 12 twitter follows
that we recommend now these are going to
be
i think in most cases
not the obvious people so you're not
gonna
my goal is even there's a lot of people
that aren't even on twitter so if you're
not on twitter maybe start
or not uh you know just subscribe to my
five tweet tuesday newsletter if you're
not doing that if you're on twitter i
bet at least half of these are going to
be people you don't already follow
that's my guess that's my goal if we do
this right so they should be kind of
under the radar rising stars and we're
going to talk about why we like these
people's feeds and some stuff that we've
seen from them that's pretty cool so
we'll go back and forth uh let's start
with uh candidate number one
are we going in order of like no best no
okay so mine are a little bit more
popular than yours so okay are you gonna
go how many do you have you have five no
i only have three
okay i was like researching
i was researching i was trying to find
ones that people the the ones i love are
people that everyone knows
but until i was like well you might have
to bring up a few or i think i bet when
i say some you're gonna think of some
others just based off that okay so we're
just going to name
12ish of them and we're going to go back
and forth let's trade off until sam runs
out so i'll go first because you're
going to run out faster otherwise so
okay the first person on my list of
twitter twitter people i think you
should follow
is post market do you follow post market
it's post underscore market no
by the way you follow thousands of
people i follow up until recently i was
following zero people
literally zero now it's like this would
be cool
i just i was getting addicted
okay so i have a list and this person's
on my list so i said post market is an
anonymous account
and um or like a pseudonymous account i
should say so it's not like a this is
not their real name or whatever post
underscore market we're going to put the
full list in the description of this
podcast so if you want to find them uh
you could do that or maybe what we'll do
is we create a twitter list that you can
just subscribe to uh that might be
easier so uh who's this person i don't
know what they do by day but there's
something in the financial world stock
you know a trader hedge fund person uh i
don't know what it says exactly in their
bio but basically what they do is
they have like hot takes
on
the market uh and it's not like hot
takes like cnbc where it's like oh
you know um the dow is up five points
it's like basically they'll take a stock
and they'll just rip it to shreds if it
doesn't make any sense so like for
example the like one of their um
one of their ones that they were killing
right now is something called the called
grove collaborative i don't know if you
saw this it's like a it was like a d2c
brand it was like one of the winning ddc
brands there's a unicorn it goes public
and then here's the tweet it says please
make it stop here is a mostly d2c
organic cleaning products business it's
doing six percent revenue growth at two
billion valuation has no plan to make
profits anytime soon and a greater than
five percent uh 5x sales multiple
grove collaborative not gonna make it
um and then it basically pulls out
things from their like investor
presentation that show like a fairly so
slow growth low margin business that is
overvalued what does growth
collaborative make i've never even heard
of that they're kind of like a
subscription almost like a whole foods
costco type of model where you can go
buy products uh from them i believe and
what what valuation are they trying to
get
i was not trying to get there they're
publicly traded at you know two two
billion or whatever yikes okay that's a
good find
and so and so this person because
they're pseudonymous they can just kind
of um talk about whatever they want
they're not really they don't pull any
punches and so like they'll go after um
they'll go after like chamath for you
know most people are kind of afraid to
like poke the bear in a way but chamoth
in reality had a bunch of really shitty
spacks where he made a bunch of money
and people who invested in his backs on
the whole like just got ripped to shreds
this year and um
and so this post-market account will
like call out
basically bad stocks bad behavior um
across the board in the stock market so
i like that like for example um our
buddy moyes tweeted something he goes
honest company went public in 2021
uh it raised 400 million that day the
shares closed at a valuation of 2.7
billion since that day it's lost 2
billion in value and is now worth less
than 800 million
and then he says public markets are
brutal be careful if you ipo and
postmarket replied and said public
markets are not brutal private markets
are a facade and it's like i like the i
like the uh the hot takes i like the
intelligence and i like uh that they
don't pull punches all right i like this
one yeah i'm gonna subscribe i'm gonna
follow um all right i'm gonna give you
one
see some of mine are popular but i'm
gonna give you three examples of why i
like them
ramit safety do you follow me on twitter
i don't follow actually i do it follow
him on twitter yeah so there's a game on
the pod i was following there's two
reasons why he's amazing the first is
when people criticize him he'll
sometimes say that's a good that's a
good criticism other times they'll be
like no you're an idiot for these
following reasons right and he also
that's reason number one so he's an
entertaining follow and reason number
two is he tweets out loads of personal
finance stuff and he'll find an article
that's going viral and if he disagrees
with it which oftentimes he does he'll
explain why it's [__] for example
uh a lot of people particularly people
who aren't necessarily wealthy have
financial advisors who charge one
percent and he'll tweet out a whole
thread about why that's total [__]
and you shouldn't pay one percent
advisor the second thing everyone talks
about buying a home and how it's a
wonderful investment and he'll tweet out
this awesome math saying no buying a
home is not an investment buying a home
is like buying a car or something like
that where you should just use it and
not do it for financial reasons because
more often than not it's not a good
investment at all
and finally he's got this really cool
tweet on how to automate money so i
actually linked to it in that sheet and
i actually set up my my accounts based
off that tweet so what do you mean by
how to automate money what does that
mean so click um so click i believe it
was this one where it says uh how he
like like where the money goes like for
example where do do you have your bank
account set up so like a percentage goes
here a percentage goes there
or like your um your paycheck
no you really so where's your money go
to well i don't get a paycheck but
you're you get paid for the hubspot
podcast you get paid for your business
so where's your income go to straight to
a checking account go straight to a
jacket account and then your boy moves
it into whatever investments i want to
make really
yeah
i think you need to read some ruby set
these stuff because like it should the
way it should work is like all your
money should go or not you could do
however you want well the way often
times i think it's easier is your money
should go to a checking account and then
it takes money out and like let's say
that you have a really simple setup put
this much in wealthfront put this much
in a mutual fund put this what do you
even use to do that i don't even know
that's a possibility that you automate
the like clawing out of your checking
into various other services yeah you
could do it with coinbase if you wanted
to you could do an automatic thing for
coinbase oh you go okay so what you do
is you go in those services you go into
wealthfront you say i'd like to do a
auto saver plan and you just ach connect
yeah exactly and you just set it up so
it's all automated so it's just like
basically like you know based off of
your monthly income roughly that you
want this much cash in your checking
account at all times and it
automatically and you kind of know
roughly the intervals of when you're
going to get cash and just funnel it
into okay so one of the reasons i didn't
do that was
when i was getting the last thing i had
last job i had when i was at twitch one
of the major sources of income was just
stock rsu's that were going into amazon
stock like automatically so that was
already that was already there and i
wasn't selling because my basis for when
i when we got acquired was lower than
the amount at the rsu grant i didn't
want to sell and rebalance because it
was going to trigger taxes uh on those
gains um
as as the price cap have you sold any of
those shares
uh yeah i sold a small amount maybe 15
are you ever going to sell any of them
i hope not uh yeah i'm on that big
borough die [__] now so uh you know
that's that that's the that's that new
game plan it's awesome right
yeah it's it's awesome until it's not
awesome it's probably probably the right
answer like most things okay i'm just
going to read these remutes money rules
all right
have one year of emergency fund cash
okay fair enough uh i don't but yeah you
can
um save 10 10 and invest 20 of your
gross income
you do that
or you go higher uh
much higher yeah
um pay cash for large expenses 20 down
minimum on a house okay fair enough yes
i do that uh never question spending
money on books appetizers health or
donate to a friend's charity razor agree
completely
business class for flights over four
hours agree completely um
no limit for spending on health or
education agree completely
buy the best and keep it for as long as
possible i disagree with that really i i
either buy the best or i buy extremely
cheap disposable where i don't have any
stress about it because
i didn't invest hoping it was going to
be the best like a razor it's like a
barbell like
i'll give an example
uh for black friday there's this brand
called 32 degrees do you know them
nobody's the costco they're like the
costco brand of under armour
or like nike so i'm gonna buy stuff from
the no is it awesome they make like they
make like athletic wear and uh it's
actually like pretty good but i don't
think it lasts as long as lululemon it
doesn't last like gym shark
yeah like it's it's just not going to
have that same durability but i like
their stuff like i like it when i wear
it and it fits well uh on my whatever
fits well for me so i you know for black
friday they have this insane deal where
like everything goes down like 85
percent they just want to move all their
inventory so you'll go buy like whatever
like athletics you know like a hoodie or
like a fitted you know long sleeve shirt
or whatever and it'll be like 4.99 and
so i just load up so i buy like almost a
thousand dollars worth of 32 degrees
stuff that day you get to see on my
floor here there's just piled the boxes
came and there's piles come out like
it's as if i'm a wholesaler for them and
so i'll buy like 15 of the pants i like
i'll buy like 25 of the shirt i like
and because of that i don't worry about
like a losing anything getting a stain
on anything something wearing out it's
like nah i i bought you this so much
laundry you have to do though
gotta clean it for the laundry bro
all right all right you're good all
right your turn i know it's bad for the
the real argument is it's terrible for
the environment and like you know fair
enough but uh
you know bird's gotta fly so here we go
uh here's his last two his last three
rules earn enough to work only with the
people i respect and like i think that's
a great rule uh marry the right person
okay fair enough doesn't seem like a
money rule but i get it
uh prioritize time outside the
spreadsheet what does that mean um so
like when you're i do i have a problem
with this all the time i'm constant i
have a spreadsheet with all my net worth
and my finances and i'm constantly
optimizing it and i'll like do different
scenarios like oh and five here if in
five years if this happens then we're
gonna be here if it goes worst case
scenario we're gonna be here therefore
we should do this this and this so i'm
like constantly tinkering with it and
doing i'm like oh three percent uh if
you only spend three percent of your net
worth over this many years but it grows
by this that means by the time we're 50
we're going to have this
right
and
that takes like that takes up so much
time it's so fun though
i see uh and also this wealth advisory
thing so we both have the same advisor
but he doesn't charge us any fee right
correct no we he only gets paid if we
buy uh some of the funds that he's gonna
sell us right okay fair enough it's
pretty sick right so i think that's kind
of a hack i think that's that's a pretty
good hack i think it's a great deal
um okay so let's do uh let's do another
person okay so you got we have post
market we have vermeet uh i'm gonna do
another one let me do
okay i'm going to give you a double a
double dose because they're kind of the
same same type of account
so
my buddy george mac
and then
there's this account called marketing
examples do you follow these no what is
this one marketing samples
so marketing examples this guy
i would say is one of the best content
creators
um
on the internet what's the handle
i think it's just marketing examples is
it good is it harry's marketing example
so there's this guy harry drive harry
dry he works with us sometimes i think
we we i discovered him a long time ago
and we tried hiring him and uh it didn't
work out but we're we love him
yeah i uh i really really respect i
don't know this person i don't i don't
know well i've damned him just kind of
showing respect uh i don't think most
people know him he's not like
widely
he's young
you know you know there's like the
circle jerk of like we all kind of like
the same things and yeah the same
circles i think he's like 18 or 19.
yeah i think he's probably a little
older than that but if he whatever he is
he's amazing his content is so good i um
i think most people when i see their
content i'm sort of cocky where i'm like
i could do better if i like if i wanted
to i could do better i see his [__] and
i say oh i should be copying things he's
doing so that's like a very very high
compliment in my book uh where i want to
copy your [__] because i think you're
doing such a good job so um so i think
he's his account's really great
and um and then george george mack is
similar in that george mac basically
tweets out kind of like
cool marketing hacks mental models
um
just interesting stories
and uh it's a george is really really
good as well and he's also kind of like
outside the scene
meaning like he wasn't he's not a
silicon valley person he's not a founder
or vc that like isn't super well
connected in this area but i think has
earned a lot of people's twitter respect
you know he's probably got i don't know
what like 70 000 followers maybe 100 000
i don't know what it is um
so george is really good also so they're
they're the ones i would say to follow
if you want
examples of what good content marketing
is as well as
kind of like uh marketing psychology
hacks is what i would call them yeah
this guy harry dry has some of the best
stuff he's like she just basically takes
landing pages and he goes this is why
this is good and he's just very simple
have you seen his his kanye west thing
what did he do
i remember something like that so ben
pull this up go to go to the
kanyeweststory.com
i think that's what it's called
so basically this is like a blog post
that he just like tricked out it's like
exhibit knocked on the door and was
there to pimp his blog
and uh maybe i got the domain wrong
maybe it's not that it's the
kanyestory.com yeah the kanyestory.com
and uh it's basically this epic website
blog post that's just like a scrolling
story about the day he got in touch with
kanye west and how it all went down and
so it's like it starts with it starts
with this like epic photo of kanye that
you scroll and it's like a slide it's
like from lying in bed with zero ideas
to negotiating with the biggest
superstar on planet earth and then it's
got this little like outline on the left
it's like the idea going viral coding it
launching it reborn billboards yeezy and
then this is those the chapters of this
story and he just tells a great a very
simple
you know hustler story but i just love
this like domain the way he designed
this blog again this guy's an artist and
i'm like i really respect him and when i
come up with [__] i think i like use him
as one of my mood boards of inspiration
of like something that i'll i'll copy or
i'll steal uh inspiration from at the at
the least this kid's amazing yeah he's
he's 25 years old that was way off i
think when we i want to do something i
want to like launch something with this
guy i don't know i i my new thing is
like i find people
who are just awesome and i find an
excuse to collab with them and i would
put both george and harry in that bucket
all right your turn um all right we're
gonna go with uh the pessimistic what's
this called the pessimist what's the
full one the pessimist archive that's
what it's called uh the handle is like
just pessimistic pessimistic arc uh so
basically what it is is it's incredibly
fascinating because it's a twitter
handle that looks back at history and
brings up topics
that people complain about today so for
example
there's a um a tweet from november 16
1918 or a news article and it says i
would rather spend the rest of my life
in jail than wear one and it's talking
about a guy who doesn't want to wear a
flue mask and then there's another
example of someone saying like uh oh
here's a quote from martin luther king
saying like you know there's too many
books out there people are trying to
write too much and become famous and
it's basically he's talking about like
influencers
uh and it's kind of funny and then this
is great there will be another one where
it's like technology is just gonna kill
our brains and they're like referring to
like a telephone and so
it's real and so if you read just the
tweet part you would think that they're
talking about now but then they show you
a different year and then they show you
a picture of the article and it's from a
newspaper from the 1800s and so it's
kind of cool because people complain
about the same [__] all the time and so
you'll think like oh our country is more
divided but divided than ever or like
the wealth gap is like crazy or right
it's like narratives that it's like yeah
all those things could be true but like
oftentimes people think it's worse than
ever before and maybe that's not the
case because people have been
complaining about the same [__] forever
like okay there's one with school
shooters and it's like um
the you know these guys were addicted to
books and they were reading these these
gory books and that's why they shot up
their like their local town instead of
video games they're blaming like this uh
the novel the dime novels whatever those
are and it really and my takeaway here
is to two things the first thing is that
we react this oftentimes human beings
react the same through for for centuries
and if you study why people react the
way they do you can begin
to predict to predict this and so if i
can if i figure out in history what have
been some of the common reactions to
action x y and z i can kind of look into
the future and or at the present time
being like okay i think people are going
to react by doing like any blank because
that's just how we're wired um the
second thing that it does is it like
brings you to like senses a little bit
where you're like okay i need to be calm
people have complained about this
literally for 150 years and we're doing
okay and uh so that's interesting and i
was reading this book human nature by
robert greene
ben i don't know if you've read the snap
maybe you could tell me but i'm almost
positive
somewhere in this book i that they said
that one of the very first bits of
written lang language that they found
was of people complaining about the
younger generation and how they aren't
going to keep the cultures that the old
or keep the traditions that the older
generation has created you know what i
mean it's this idea of like old people
complaining about young people being
lazy like
one of the very first evident pieces of
evidence of of of written language it
was a story of complaining about that
so anyway yeah i like seeing those
patterns so that's mine yeah that's uh
you know what's the phrase history
doesn't repeat itself but it rhymes yes
and uh that's that's like what this
account is you know in a nutshell
there's some really great ones on this i
have a similar
stash uh in my swipe file that i've been
keeping for for years i kind of forgot
to update it recently but it was called
smart people saying dumb things
and i would say
anytime
somebody who is clearly smart and
successful
said something that was very wrong so
for example you know warren buffett uh
was very very dismissive of like you
know certain technologies what you know
bitcoin today but before that you know
internet and technology stocks um that
he just didn't understand that he didn't
understand them and so therefore made
some disparaging comments or um
like ray dalio predicting like a crisis
in the 80s
yeah or um you know steve ballmer
laughing and saying you know when he's
cackling and saying nobody will ever buy
a thousand dollar phone like they just
don't get apple you know apple will fail
or whatever so i did that
partly because there's like a
in the moment there's like a junk food
fun of it which is like ha
yes wrong you know there's a joy when
somebody's successful is pointed out to
be very wrong about something but
there's more than that the real reason i
did it was to remind myself that like
it's very easy to kind of go into hero
worship mode
and to idolize certain people or put
them on a pedestal and just because
you're smart in one thing doesn't mean
you're smart in another or just because
you're right a lot doesn't mean you're
right all the time it's a very important
lesson because i've made big mistakes
like for example
i think i've missed out
i bought tesla stock very early on i
think i bought it
under a hundred dollars a share and i
think if you uh if you adjust for the
splits i think it's now over like five
thousand dollars a share so i think i've
i would have made about five million
dollars on stock buy that i had really
if i just held and um
and the reason i didn't hold wasn't
because i wanted to take profits it was
because i got spooked by
first there was like a lot of people at
a given time that were called tesla q do
you know about that uh was that the
thing where they said that like the it's
fake like their factories are fake
but it's not that the factories are fake
but that there's sort of like fraud
deception that the fundamentals don't
make sense and that tesla's going to go
to zero
josh wolfe the guy like spreading those
yes exactly so josh so there was mostly
anonymous accounts on twitter and reddit
and so i had read it and i was like okay
i always want to learn what is the other
side i was so bullish on tesla this at
this point tesla wasn't even anywhere
near where it is today right um and so
it was like
okay you know tesla's gone from 90 a
share where i bought it to 380 a share
great but like you know i still think
it's got a lot of room to run and and i
was reading i always want to know what
is the what do people who disagree with
me say and what's their argument do i do
i believe it
and so i read it i was like ah there is
some weird stuff like wow they've gone
through 25 cfos like that sounds strange
like why does the cfo keep leaving and
like
the people would have this like drone
footage of like parking lots just full
of teslas that they're taking like why
are they stashing teslas in these
parking garages look at this every car
in this six door car garage is a tesla
why is it here what are they are they
faking deliveries and sales like what
what is this so there was a lot of like
wait there's fire was there any truth in
any of this
honestly or here's my honest take i
actually think that there was a lot of
truth to what was going on i think that
and the reason why i say this is i don't
think it's as bad as they said but i
also don't think it's as good as tesla
portrayed it meaning i think there
actually was a period of time where
tesla almost died where it actually
almost did go bankrupt because um of
like the combination of the production
ramp up was going too slow they had the
production line was not moving fast
enough uh the subsidies were there but
they could have gone away and like all
this stuff and i think there was like a
lot of um
kind of like you know fake until you
make it going on there and elon has even
come out and said in the past he goes he
was talking about
when um when clean tech was big and the
government was giving money to this
thing was called solyndra or something
like that and he came out and he said
same thing happened with enron where it
was like five weeks before it went under
they were like not just saying
everything's gonna be okay they were
saying everything's better than ever
and he eddie alon came out i was sort of
like what do you want people to say he's
like you know it is in the incentive of
somebody of the captain of that ship
to go down with the ship and the whole
time be saying oh we're so close to our
destination basically he was like
they're never going to come out and say
yeah
we don't know we might not make it
because then that will guarantee you
don't make it because people will sell
the stock it'll put so much negative
pressure on the company it'll hurt the
morale inside the company and so you
can't ever come out and say i don't know
we might not make it so you always have
to say
make it of course we're gonna make it
we're thriving
and like you just hope it actually comes
true he said something to that effect in
an interview once i read and i was like
i feel like he's describing what
actually was going on inside tesla
that's amazing so anyways the long story
short was i didn't believe it didn't
believe it didn't believe it i was sort
of like
reading it but i didn't pull the trigger
and then josh wolfe this guy's a very
very smart guy successful vc not an
anonymous twitter egg account who's like
just shorting the stock and trying to
like spread fear
um he was really [__] on it
consistently for the course of a year
and at some point i was like you know
what will i regret more selling the
stock now and taking my profit if i'm
wrong or
seeing all these signals and not like
going with what seems to be a mounting
amount of evidence how much did you buy
guess what i was wrong tesla becomes
elon becomes the richest man in the
world tesla becomes a 600 billion dollar
company i bought it at a 6 billion
valuation or something crazy like that
and so you know i missed out on a 50-100
x uh you know somewhere along the way
and uh and so yeah i do regret i
actually turned out to be wrong i would
have regretted more of this scenario
happening but it seemed improbable wait
so you bought a hundred grand worth of
tesla stock
i didn't buy a hundred grand i think i
bought like
i don't know i don't even know what it
was it wasn't 100 i don't think that was
that's not what i was buying back then
because this was like
i was like 23 years old or something at
the time it was a long time ago and
basically i think i bought like 30 or 40
grand of the stock at a certain price
and i because i remember doing the math
and thinking okay they're valued at like
five or six billion now
what is ford and gm value okay they're
valued at 25 billion okay on one hand
that seems crazy that they're only five
times less when they deliver like 200
times less cars but i was like i really
think like the cars are gonna go
electric that these old [__] are never
going to switch
and he's got this like vertically
integrated it's like actually a battery
and energy company it's not even a car
company and this was before self-driving
because it wasn't
so it was a good place yeah but you know
if you get it wrong you get it wrong so
egg on my face and by the way on this
note of
the the pessimist archive
i saw this youtube video that was um i
don't know if you heard about this a few
years ago elon musk negotiated a very
unique compensation package do you know
about this uh yeah basically he gets
some crazy bonuses if some crazy goals
happened
yeah so he had
he had set up this thing where he gets
absolutely
his entire compensation was tied to
the um the market cap of tesla and like
it was at 50 billion i think at the time
when he had done it and um
it was like every 50 billion dollars
increments he was gonna get more and so
i was like if i get us to 100 billion
then i get x i get i think he would get
uh
like one percent or two percent more of
the company each time i i i i should
have i don't know we're gonna talk with
this i could have mapped it out but
basically he was going to get a
percentage more of the company for every
50 billion they go up in market cap as
they also have to hit certain um like
revenue and earnings uh
at that time and he had no guaranteed
income so basically if tesla just went
from 50 to 99 billion he would get zero
during that time
and he had five years to do it and the
top of the compensation plan was if they
became
a 600 billion dollar company then he was
going to become like he was going to get
this like he would own like 10 percent
of whatever he would own some ridiculous
amount
that would get unlocked for him and he
would be essentially the richest man in
the world and there's all these there's
this clip of uh what's his name andrew
sorkin or whatever his name is the guy
on cnbc fast money or whatever
um of them they're outlining the plan
and they're laughing they're just
laughing at them they're like
i don't even know why they included
these tears like for tesla to get that
would be uh there's no way and they're
all laughing like there's no chance and
they're like this is such a weird thing
why did he do this and they're like
basically laughing at him and saying how
outrageous the top end of it was where
it just made no sense it's like well to
do that temple tesla would need to
become like the fifth most valuable
company in the world or third most
valuable company in the world and
they're like that's ridiculous but i
guess you know aim high i guess
no guaranteed compensation of any time
of any kind at all he gets no salary
cash bonus equity uh he only gets equity
that that vests over time but only if he
reaches uh these hurdle rates which are
dare i say crazy so right now the
company's worth 59 billion dollars
they run at 50 billion dollar increments
so if he gets the company to 100 billion
you're just talking market
capitalization not based on revenue now
based on the number of production
there's going to be two metrics at each
step so the first step is he has to get
the company to 100 billion dollars
and reach these operational and adjusted
ebitda and revenue number if he doesn't
get either of them he gets nothing
that's kind of a weird way to break it
down based on he gets to 150
and has to hit the operational numbers i
mean the market can be irrational so
can't control that at each 50 billion
dollar number he collects one percent of
the company if somehow magically he
would get the company to 650 billion
dollars which is literally what the plan
calls for if you can believe this uh he
would collect the equivalent of about
55. what a million dollars in
compensation otherwise he gets
absolutely what if you get it to 650
billion dollars and then immediately and
then sure enough he he's like i think he
just hit it or he's about to hit that
that last final thing and sure enough
he's the richest man in the world now
that's badass better on yourself i need
to go back well if you're him
all right i'm going to tell you a handle
that would have helped you so you know
who ryan holiday is definitely right yes
uh ryan holiday is an author just kind
of like a personality but mostly an
author and he does stoicism stuff and i
included him but i'm gonna actually tell
you the one you should follow so i like
ryan holiday because he's got these
things that are not business related but
help me in business and help me in life
and so he's got five lessons from seneca
seneca was a
greek i actually don't know what he was
uh he's a philosopher uh and so they are
we suffer what was he
i think he was greek i i didn't look it
up it was roman ben thank you
uh we suffer more imagination or five
stoic lessons from seneca we suffer more
in imagination than in reality associate
only with people who improve you the
greatest remedy for anger this is the
best one the greatest remedy for anger
is delay
nice
value your time more than your
possessions and death is not in the
distant future we are dying every day
and he's got these amazing things that i
love
but he's got this other twitter handle
called the daily stoic i love the daily
stoic and they just like tweet out all
these like
interesting stoicism
that's his right it's his brand it's his
and it's incredibly useful this stuff is
like it's one of the stoicisms one of
the few philosophies that's like
actively um it's practical and you could
use on a daily basis and so i like
following this account it reminds me to
do certain things okay so correct me if
i'm wrong so
uh i had heard about stoicism from ryan
holiday tim ferriss bunch of others so i
go i buy meditations by marcus aurelius
i sit down i start to read it and i'm
sort of just trying to understand what
the heck is this philosophy
and there were some things i thought
really cool like the tweet like that
tweet you just read out those five
principles like that resonates with me
but there was like a part of it which
was sort of like
feel neither the highs nor the low it
seemed almost like a philosophy and i
think i'm wrong so i want you to correct
me uh it seemed like a philosophy which
was sort of like feel nothing yeah and i
think that you're i feel nothing doesn't
seem very fun why do i want to feel
nothing so that's my big that's my
actually a really good criticism in my
opinion of stoicism and it's my
criticism of stoicism which is a lack of
joy and a lot of stoics this is me a
steel arm steel manning by the way a lot
of stoics will say um no like there's
joy like if you read it differently
there's room for joy or they never say
you can't have joy and they're not wrong
but oftentimes it's how to deal with
pain and misery and the idea is
basically you accept the fact that
you're going to come into contact with a
bunch of idiots all day who are going to
want to hurt you and steal from you but
that's okay you do like a negative
visualization right you like imagine
things going wrong which again just
feels very
not so fun for me and not the way i have
not not that's not a formula that's
worked for me in fact the exact opposite
has worked for me that formula has
worked for me actually so what i do is
like all right today i've got cancer i
can't get out of bed because
i'm like harsh you do this every day i
do it a lot or i'll be like look like
like if i'm feeling sad i'll be like my
i just got my leg cut off like i can't
walk i wish i could run sports and then
i'll be like wait a minute i have both
legs i'm don't feel sick
let's go celebrate and exercise
or you know what i mean or like you know
i'm happy my dog is not dead
and i'll go and it makes me appreciate
him yeah it's called negative
visualization i think it's incredibly
useful
there's a there's this is this is to me
so i will disagree with this there's a
this to me is the argument of well
there's kids starving in africa like in
any given moment you could just sort of
remember oh there's kids starving in
africa this kid's starving in africa my
boyfriend broke up with me well at least
i'm gonna keep staring in africa and um
and i
i get the utility of it i've used it
myself
but in my experience i've learned that
it's a bit of a roundabout way to a
destination of gratitude and like you
don't have to go
to
feeling the stress and the pain and the
suffering of bad in order to feel the
gratefulness around the good and so i
found it i guess my personal experience
has been i think it's a roundabout way
to gratitude and like i might as well
just go straight to gratitude don't need
to uh
don't need to think about all the bad
things think about worry about all the
bad things that could happen and go
there this it's not been useful for me i
remember like when i get a sore throat i
always feel this way and when i get like
a toothache i'm like i wish i could go
back to the days where my tooth didn't
hurt like if you had like a toothache is
like the most pain you could be in or
sometimes and i'm like i like you're
like i i don't remember like sometimes
it might if all the women who have given
birth are like what the [__] is good
talking about well yeah but like i do
think is the worst pain you could feel
or like like in my like whenever i get
earaches and toothaches i'm like you
know it's like it's like this internal
pain it's like i can't make the pain
stop and i just have to deal with it
until i have an appointment in three
days and then you get like two days in
and you're like i don't remember what it
felt like to not feel this pain
and so i got into the habit i'd be like
i would be so thankful if i could if my
throat didn't hurt today and i could
just swallow food that would make me so
happy
and days when i don't i'm not sick i try
to think back i'm like this is exactly
what i wanted i wanted to feel happy
that i'm not sick today and so i think
about that stuff all the time so anyway
ryan holiday and the daily stoic is a
good follow you're up
all right um by the way i know we didn't
do stoicism justice for people who are
like
die-hards sorry uh people should look i
don't think it is no emotions i think
it's like more subtle than that but but
that's a really good i think your
criticism's great which is like i think
it's what a lot of people run into
getting excited and then they're like
wait but wait is this what i want yeah
it's like where's the room for fart
jokes you know what i mean
i'm gonna give you two niche experts
they're in different niches but i like
them okay so uh i should link their
accounts here for you too
uh
this first guy i don't know exactly how
you say his name
his name is
aviral bhatnagar uh and i'm gonna link
you his twitter it's aviralbat and uh
i'm gonna put it uh where do i put it i
put on the sheet that we have okay you
got it
so this guy avi aviral bottnecker he is
a venture capitalist in india
and his blog is at juniorvc.com
this guy puts out really really high
signal stuff around what's going on in
india um like for example he has a tweet
that he put out yesterday or that was
india now exports more software 133
billion then saudi arabia exports oil
113 billion we are the india is the
largest engineering population in the in
the world uh what an amazing story
that's come come out over the last 40
years how did you find this guy this is
the best this one's the best one though
this is the most
helpful one on the list yeah and so like
i i do a lot of investing in indian
startups and i was like okay if i'm
gonna invest in a new startup i'm not on
the ground i'm not the like local domain
expert so what did i do i invested in a
fund i became an investor in somebody
else's fund that's india focused i was
like okay cool i'm gonna get insights
from him and i can bounce any deal off
him to see if he wants to participate
and maybe he has a local view that i
don't understand and then this was
another guy that i thought was really
smart so i wanted to find who i wanted
to basically see who's the thought
leader in that space and then how do i
subscribe to them and so his um you know
his like blog i think has 50 000
subscribers now so he's not like you
know no name uh but he's very niche and
he talks about kind of like the indian
tech scene and what's going on you know
at a macro level whatever so i found
this guy to be i think he's doing a
really good job of content creation so
i'm going to pick this guy in one niche
is there such a thing as this for china
uh i'm sure there is actually this is a
good idea i should just um
like find this person for like vladim
for europe you know for different parts
of europe and for for india for china
and for australia maybe um so if there
is none
be this guy this guy is a valuable
position to become super valuable
there's this guy named bill
bishop i think his name is bill bishop
had a newsletter
uh called steinism i think it's called
you know what i'm talking about no um
cyno cynocism i don't know what that
means uh cynicism um s-i-n-o-c-i-s-m
for a long time he was the most popular
guy on sub-stack and his entire
newsletter is it's called get smarter
about china and he just tells you about
the business of china and you can see
all the latest trends coming out of
china it would be a really great
arbitrage to do by the way if you yeah
instead of trying to compete in the same
pond as everybody else like
go provide a really useful bridge into
one specific market or one specific
geography
um like i i i've told the story before i
think but like one of the most
influential people in my life was this
teacher named lisa keister at duke
university and she taught this class
called getting rich and her story was
she graduated what was the name of the
class the name of the class yeah did
everyone take that it was it was one of
the hardest classes to get into because
it was a great name great title right so
you already know this person's not just
like every other professor like she
understands like her customer her market
the second thing was she was the highest
rated professor on like
ratemyprofessor.com and greatest thing
she had a chili pepper next to her name
so she was like hot too it was like oh
it was everything so i i wake up at five
in the morning we go to the library to
get on the highest speed internet
connection and as soon as the course
listings open up we like jumped on it
and we got into this class and i go in
and she was she tells her story she goes
actually i was a student at duke 10
years ago or 11 years ago whatever it
was she goes i graduated with a degree
in mandarin because that's just what was
interesting to me and at the time
everybody was making fun of me
actually she was older than this now but
she had started teaching back when she
was like 32 or something now she might
be 42 or 50 or something like that but
she goes i graduated with this degree
all my like friends were like good luck
with that you know how's that mandarin
degree gonna kind of help you out get a
job here because i'm a i'm gonna go to
med school i'm gonna be a lawyer i'm
gonna be a consultant like what are you
gonna do with that chinese degree and
she's like well i bet i can get a job in
china
like what and so she bought a one-way
ticket just goes to china and she just
starts waving her hand she's like hey
people in china like i
know english i know companies in the
west um
and i would love to learn about you and
then be a bridge and she became a bridge
basically between companies in china and
companies in america if an american
company wanted to do business china they
would do it through her because she like
could translate the not just literally
the language but like
she knew who to talk to she became like
the local expert there she be and this
like to me this guy on twitter he's my
bridge and knowing what's going on in
the scene in india and so what her story
was she made a killing doing that
because it was really valuable companies
in china really wanted to do business
with the companies in the west
then she invested all of it in the tech
and the tech stock market because she
was like oh i can tell tech companies
are the ones that are doing well she and
then right before the bubble burst she
pulled it all out to be like i want to
do real estate now and she just timed it
perfectly accidentally invested all in
real estate from 2000 2008 right before
the real estate crash happened she took
it out again because she just wanted to
do something else with her life and
basically by 32 was retired and like you
know uh was like what i want to do i
want to go teach and teach kids what i
wish i knew back then how wealthy she
got
i think she made like you know a few
million dollars at least and like you
know probably like five seven million
dollars and like
um you know she wants she lives in in
durham and she teaches at school i mean
i have no idea so what was the class
totally i'm totally guessing so the
class was
basically was you know like ramit sethi
was like personal finance which is like
she's like you probably need she wanted
to teach what she wished she learned
when she was in school so she's like i
wish they taught you about how to manage
money so she would show us like the
power of compound interest over time
like why you should save early and
versus saving more money when you're 30
versus saving even a little bit of money
when you're 20.
and then like what is a mortgage and
like how does that work and like
then so and then every other class you
would just invite in someone who made it
like someone who's successful
financially but doing a completely
different thing just to expose you to
like look there's like 50 pats dude this
is like this podcast pretty much yeah
one would be this girl who started a
t-shirt company licensing university
logos and she would tell her story then
she got jamie diamond on the phone and
like jimmy diamond is like you know the
head of whatever
stanley or whatever uh and like then she
had this hedge fund guy from san
francisco come out and he's like yeah
here's what he's like he surveyed the
room he goes do you guys use uh
microsoft or apple products and there
and people are answering he goes
uh he asked like three questions and we
were like why did you ask that he goes
because then i'm only gonna make one
decision this year and it's whether to
invest like hundreds of millions of
dollars into apple or not
and um and he's like so all i'm doing is
i'm just trying to figure out what is
the right decision on that and i was
like whoa
that's a job that's a that's epic and he
he had said in his when he was in the
class he goes by the way uh all you guys
are gonna just have the same resume he
goes you're all trying to do the same
thing you're all trying to get grades
and then like these internships he's
like so the first three fourths of your
resume think about it it's gonna look
the same as everybody else in this room
like i'm not really going to be able to
tell the difference he goes the only
thing that's going to differentiate any
of you is that bottom section where it's
called other like other interests he's
like so at this school everybody's going
to teach you to like work on that top
three fourths of the resume in reality
you should be working on the bottom the
bottom one fourth of that resume because
that's what guys like me look at
everybody's got a degree everybody's got
good grades everybody went to a good
school i've never have i told you about
the bottom fourth of the resume
no what is that that's so funny that you
you even use that fraction i always tell
my when when i own the company i would
say i just care about the bottom fourth
i'd always say just temp this wow and i
would always say that and i'd be like
one of the greatest people ask me how do
you find good writers i was like well
here's one really easy way ask them
about the bottom fourth and they go what
do you mean i was like well
just it didn't matter what they studied
in school ask them um okay so you
majored in philosophy what's your
favorite uh philosophy class or favorite
philosophy teacher and if they can't
tell me a story about something that
they spent four years and hundreds of
thousands of dollars on then they're
just not going to be a good writer
because they're not interesting enough
right and so i would always ask about
the bottom fourth of the resume for all
types of roles because i'm like if
you're just if you can't entertain me
for this conversation and then you just
don't have any passion and i don't want
to be around you
right
that's amazing okay so maybe this
becomes one of the the core frameworks
that's a you know one one person saying
it that's just a dot two people saying
hey that's a line i interviewed uh i got
that from uh gold brian goldberg who
founded uh bustle and he has this
amazing article and he says it's
headlined losers exist stay away from
them and it's basically like how to only
hire winners it's from pando from years
and years ago and he's a brilliant
writer but he doesn't write anymore
because he's kind of a loose cannon but
it was titled losers exist how to avoid
them and it talks about uh one of the
best ways to ask about the bottom fourth
and if you're you're a loser if you
can't like be passionate about something
that you spent four years studying ah no
dude this article is gone
it's is it
panda you know like pando died let me
see if there's a cache version
there is a cache version uh okay we're
back in luck the headline is losers
exist don't hire them yeah awesome
um okay let's do uh let's do a couple
more i'm gonna give a couple quick ones
uh okay this other person who i think is
a niche expert is this guy willy woo do
you follow him no i'm looking him up now
i'm following all these people the the
indian guy is the best one so far but
let's look at willy woo yeah i don't
think you'll like this one because it's
very crypto specific but this guy willy
woo is i think the leading
crypto analyst
and um you know in most things like
these people who analyze charts and
stuff like that they're like
it's a little bit like horoscopy they're
like oh look the trend is going this way
and like if you draw this t shape it's
going to be the iron cross pattern and
like you know so bye bye bye and um
in crypto there's one unique thing which
is that all the data
is there's a lot more transparency all
the you know everything that's happening
is happening on a chain on a public
blockchain so you can actually go
analyze it so like he looks at all these
metrics that are like
um
you know he won't just look at the price
for example there's things like what is
the actual average buy-in price because
it's one thing for the price to go up or
for people to like not be selling
because they bought it in 2013 and they
you know their cost basis was like five
dollars and your cost basis now is 50
000 so it looks at like what the actual
price people buying in what is the
average price people bought in for and
that tells you like
if it's low versus the actual price
you're like okay um you know it's mostly
you know it's mostly just same coins and
old hands versus if it's higher you
realize that people are buying in at the
current price levels and that's pulling
the average up um
and so there's there's a whole bunch of
things like that like um coin age like
um are old coins moving meaning like if
og believers start selling that's kind
of a signal like it's like when a ceo
starts selling their stock it's like
wait why are you selling your stock that
doesn't seem quite right um
what's the reason and so like when a
bunch of old hands start selling that's
actually a signal that comes before the
price changes it may not even affect the
price yet but it's an indicator of
something to come damn all right i just
follow them so this guy's got all kinds
of analysis and he's a lot more
reasonable so crypto is full of
especially crypto twitter is full of
like just propaganda artists and they're
good at it they're like
they will make you believe that some
random [__] nft is the hottest [__]
because it's like one guy controlling 55
bot accounts and they're all replying to
every tweet that uses the word you know
art with like a link to their freaking
project there's so much propaganda
there's so much noise and there's so
many like
just believers who if you say if i if i
just go out there to say and i say my
price prediction for 2022
is six six million dollars a coin
um i'll get a bunch of attention because
people want to believe that number's
going to keep going up and so this guy
is a lot more reasonable like he's still
obviously a big believer he's super
bullish on bitcoin and cryptocurrency in
general but he
grounds it at least in like real
analysis and i find that to be quite
valuable all right i follow them i think
that's cool is he what what does he like
actually make predictions
yeah he'll make predictions but it's not
he's not like he doesn't get just like
intoxicated which is prediction after
prediction it's more like let me explain
the way things are moving and then when
a move happens he'll explain what
actually happened who actually was it a
big one whale dumping was it a lot of
old hand selling what's causing this
bear market he'll say look there was
actually a lot of leverage in china
and those got liquidated and that's what
drove the price down and like you could
get an explanation for like what
otherwise feels like pretty arbitrary
price movements
damn that's badass all right let me give
you one um rohin dwar i actually don't
know how to spell rohin's last name or
say robertine's last name it's d-h-a-r
so this guy uh founded this company
called priceonomics you remember
pricinomics
yes i've followed this guy this guy's
good okay so he's interesting price in
amex was interesting we actually
recruited a bunch of people from there
and i love that company i don't know if
it's really around anymore but it's just
a blog but his new like started as a
side hustle now it's kind of like a
full-time thing and i actually showed
you two examples even silly's commenting
on it and this guy he owns i think 12 or
10 or eight somewhere in that eight to
12 range he owns eight single family
homes uh in new mexico in california
hawaii
wherever
and you can go and look and he'll kind
of show you where they are and i'll show
pictures of them and he'd rent him out
on airbnb and sometimes when his kids
are on vacation or not school he'll go
and stay in his homes and he reveals all
of the numbers and all of the updates so
on december 6 he tweeted these are my
monthly mortgage payments on each of the
homes in my small
portfolio vacation rentals
uh another one is he'll say like you
know currently we're seeing this type of
occupancy rate and we actually just
added a surfboard to our house in hawaii
and we noticed that we could get more
money for it or something like that and
he takes screenshots and he shows all of
the revenue that he's making as well as
how much money things have cost uh cost
him to buy and he'll even do things like
recently he posted a couple listings
he's like i think i could turn this into
an airbnb and he'll just like
link to the redfin
house listing and he's like i think i
can get these numbers so it's actually
really cool to see him in real time make
it all happen
yeah i like this this is awesome uh i
didn't realize that he was doing this
this is it's kind of new
yeah he's been at it for a while he's
been at it for now his new stick he's
doing it for six years but he doesn't
think he was i don't think he was as
public about it he wasn't as public
about it he was not as public about it
but now he's like all in on it and it's
so fun uh it's a really fun handle to
follow because
sometimes his properties are like
a quarter of a million and he puts down
20 so he puts down or sometimes even
less i think so he'll put down like 40
or 50 000 on these properties and that's
pretty attainable for a lot of people
and so it's kind of interesting
right
um okay i have a okay let's do a couple
funny ones um
okay have you heard of this account
james friedman it's fjme0013
uh
what is it on this list no so what is it
james friedman
james fridman or i don't know maybe it's
friedman but it's f-r-i-d
f-r-i-d-m-n uh no who
uh so he is uh he's got two million
followers he's definitely popular he's
the photoshop guy so basically people
will photoshop like uh hey james my
boyfriend's wearing this calvin klein
photo the same camouflage t-shirt and
every um
and every photo that we i take with them
can you just remove the the logo of
calvin klein
and then like he he does the request but
he doesn't it's not actually just
photoshopping it he makes it hilarious
so like it's very visual so you know you
need like youtube to be able to see what
i'm saying here but like he photoshopped
the the his guys wearing calvin klein
shirt of like it you know just says
across the chest calvin klein jeans and
uh so he like photoshopped it with that
ripped off so that little section ripped
off now you can just see his chest and
uh so it's like it actually like [__]
up the photo it doesn't make it good
like the girl wants uh and it says
calvin klein tattooed on his chest now
instead of on the shirt um
and so it's like uh like people will
just be like you know um
you know we here's my wedding photo uh
but we forgot to wear a mask during our
wedding photos can you photoshop a mask
on instead of photoshopping a covered
mask he'll put like you know the green
mask from jim carrey's like the mask on
their face so it's just like
people request it and then he does the
like he does the request but he does it
wrong in a way that they're not happy
with um they'll be like you know my my
arms look too big here and then he'll
make them like absurdly tiny or whatever
and so it's just hilarious like
followers he's like i look funny with
one arm and then so he just or you can't
see my other arm so it looks funny with
just one arm and so he just deletes the
the second arm so the person's armless
yeah exactly uh and i think he has like
a book or something like called the joy
of photoshop it's it says uh asking the
wrong guy for help
this is awesome
this is cool i've never seen this i'm
gonna follow him uh you wanna go do a
few more quick funny ones
uh yeah let's do another one uh we have
a friend nikita beer he's pretty funny
in like the tech world um what do you
think his account hilarious he's a
[__]
yeah i'm actually amazed that he does
some of the stuff that he does and
that's why i like them well it's kind of
like the donald trump rule right which
is like you say one offensive or weird
thing um you know you're canceled but
you say all offensive and weird things
uh you're you get like you know you get
the pass how did you get away with it
that's that's the key is like if every
post makes fun of something that's cool
if only one does then you're an [__]
all this stuff is making fun of
something so i think it's a great follow
and his profile picture is hilarious
yeah his profile picture is uh is good
um all right we want to do one more
um
yeah okay i like this one i don't know
if you know this guy i don't think you
do i don't know if you'd be interested
in him his name is harala bob
what's he do
so haraldabob's story is kind of crazy
he's a crypto guy
so he's he's actually he's transitioned
from being the the one thing guy to the
next thing guy to the next guy okay so
he started off
he got famous because he was this big
sports bettor and he famously one year
and i think the year 2000
like just absolutely raked it in in
vegas because he found an arbitrage
that he could bet on and he just like
milked it and he realized that like i
think it was something
he's had a few of these where he bis
phase he finds he would find
inefficiencies in the sports betting
market and that's how he made like
millions of dollars so he found like one
year that
what they would do is
um let's say that they would have an
over under a total points for a game and
let's say it's 200 points for the game
um
now vegas is like weirdly accurate with
over unders like they will get it like
so spot-on it'll come down to like the
last possession and like it'll flip over
or under so they're very good at doing
that it doesn't seem like there's much
inefficiency there but like in
basketball what happens is that the
first half
of basketball you just play and then you
go to halftime but at the end of the
game there's often this situation where
the losing team will start fouling the
winning team to like stop the clock make
them shoot free throws and then try to
like they're trying to make threes while
the other team can only shoot two
freezers at a time so what it led to was
that the second half
had more points than the first half
but vegas had this small bet called the
they would take the over under and it
would say you can bet the first half
over under it it was just dividing it by
two so it's like dividing the total by
two so the total was always really
accurate but the the first half over
under was underpriced it was oh it was
like too frequently too uh too high so
he was just betting the under so he'd
find these like little inefficiencies
certain refs are really foul prone um
and so he would know that okay when that
ref is reffing this game that team is
gonna score more than their normal
average and so he he would analyze the
refs when nobody was analyzing the refs
and he would just bet for a whole season
on just the refs um and he actually unco
i think he figured out before the nba
uncovered that that ref tim donahue was
like cheating basically because like it
was always weird [__] happening on that
guy's games uh and and so i i'm
paraphrasing because he doesn't like
totally out his whole strategy but like
he's talked about it before like you
know the lakers in one year were
undervalued in a way and so he was able
to bet them so he made millions of
dollars doing that
and i think he then he became um
then he gets hired by an nba mark cuban
hires him to be his like secret weapon
for the maps yeah but he only worked
there for a few days right no he worked
there for like a year or two and then he
famously you know left or slapped left
slash got fired this year he left but
like an article came out saying
everybody in the company hates parallel
bob because he has mark cuban's ear and
like you know he has too much power for
like his like random position as special
advisor and stuff like that that made
him seem like this like master puppeteer
and whatever he left uh and now he's
like big time and he's been he's been
big time into crypto recently and so
he's just like at the intersection of
all my interests like sports betting
poker gambling nba games and like nba
personnel stuff franchise management and
now crypto and so i just think this
guy's like kind of a baller degenerate
gambler type of dude and he kind of
looks like a [__] so i like him
automatically and he's not afraid to
talk [__] because he's not like employed
by you know somebody or whatever uh so
you know he
uh he basically like
um
he's kind of like a one-man band which i
think is great i think those people tend
to be the most interesting because they
could speak their mind and he's kind of
like a [__] degenerate gambler type
so he's got you know the sense of humor
that you find when you run in those
circles which is like
you know part like smart alec because
you're just like actually really [__]
smart and clever and you're finding like
the edges uh but also part [__]
where you're just like you don't mind
just making fun of people and calling
them dumb this episode turned into like
the slumdog millionaire of um twitter
where like we name
we named ten things and then a super
in-depth story on each one and why it's
interesting
yeah
yeah that's true actually it's more
about their backstories than their
twitter i think it's going to be cool um
ben what do you think are people going
to dig
stuff like this people are gonna love it
people love lists like sean said we sold
out but you know what this is a good
thing to sell out for because it's a
good episode
we um we had one title the other day
either was the title or is the thumbnail
like they used a thumbnail that i looked
stupid or a title that made me sound
like an idiot and i was like ben i don't
like that he goes oh
you thought that selling out to the
algorithm was going to feel good
[Laughter]
yeah i had them change the title also
for the hassam hassabinaj episode it
came out it was like
reveals all his comedy secrets and i was
like i don't even we didn't even talk
about that
like we didn't he didn't even talk about
his comedy secrets and uh
you know i feel like that's a guest i'm
trying to look cool with man you kind of
like making me look dumb in front of my
friend i'm trying to look cool with so
can we like change that
like you can make me look dumb but don't
make me look dumb in front of somebody
who i care about
are you guys friends now
uh yeah we're buddies that's great
that's that's pretty i feel like that's
a big a big thing right like you're
you're friends with like a guy who's
almost a hero
a strange description well like i don't
know i didn't know how much you looked
up to him but i knew you looked up to
him a lot okay there's there's
definitely like a part of it which i
think uh you know is kind of like the
embarrassing part of anybody where it's
like
you know like i find it really
embarrassing when people see a celebrity
and they [__] lose their mind and
they go and they like take a photo with
them and they like ask them for an
autograph like can you please write your
name on this piece of paper like
i mean it's a real like [__] move if
you think about it it's very strange you
know if i had my memory wiped and i came
back into society i'd be like well you
just did what like you know why did you
use yourself
that's how i used to think when i would
see people with like trump flags or any
other politician flag or they're like
his face i'm like it's kind of weird to
have a grown man's face all over your
body
yeah exactly and then like you know i
fanboy about ufc and [__] like that i
get super excited so there's you know
there's still people that like i still
can fanboy about
so there's definitely that part of it
which is like oh it's kind of cool that
someone someone that's kind of famous is
like your friend but that wears off
after like i don't know 10 seconds um or
at least for me i'm like this is like a
lame feeling
um the thing i like is that he actually
is super helpful like uh he asked
released a question like first of all we
was like okay let's take let's take uh
his career and my career completely out
of it
if you have a conversation with this
person do you like them do you get along
like do you do they say interesting
things or is it just boring same old
same old commentary that everybody has
like no dude's super interesting has
really good questions that has cool
opinions then the second part of it is
um are you gonna like like i told you
this framework which is good friends
consume together great friends create
together and so i told them i said dude
a dream of mine is to like do like a
10-minute comedy set someday like i just
think that would be such a thrill such a
challenge
you know like that's one of the few
things that i can make you know
make me you know nervous or scared it's
gonna help is the idea of doing that and
so he like i didn't even ask him for
help i would never like i wouldn't
really ask for help like dude your
time's a lot more valuable than helping
me with my like hobby dream you know um
like yeah i'm that like kind of out of
shape guy who wants to wear the jersey
and dribble up and down the court in
madison square garden like yeah i want
that but like you don't need to help me
but he has he texts me like really
interesting
kind of like the stuff i'm you know you
know i'm a nerd about which is like
frameworks kind of like techniques
tactics of like okay what's behind the
laugh
the laugh doesn't just happen
you know like there's a there's like
there's there's a there's a way to
consistently recreate the laugh how do
you do that and so he's been sharing
some ideas with me and so you have to
ask him be like can i share this tweet
or can i share this text i did ask him i
was like dude you should charge for this
like this is unbelievable he's like
he's like hey don't share my [__] i was
like okay i'll go to the grave with it
and then b
so i haven't told nobody no not even not
even my right-hand man i don't don't
don't even let him take a peek then the
second part was
uh he's like you know there's like this
feeling in like a comedy and like acting
which is like
you could teach it but like if you teach
it that's sort of like this like signal
of like i couldn't do it so i became
that acting teacher in you know new york
or whatever
and i think there's that same thing in
tech which is like
are you like teaching it because you
like you couldn't make it as the
operator i think there is that stigma in
tech as well but much less so because in
tech people figured out if i start
blogging about my [__] and tweeting
about my [__] i get my reputation goes
up i get better deal flow i get to
invest in better more badass companies
it's like actually strategic
right and it's not like that versus like
a fallback plan well i'm very eager sean
to hear about your friendship with with
this famous comedian
[__] you
[__] you for doing that
congratulations i'm making a new friend
to tell you a text on why that was funny
yeah for some of us it's natural
yeah dissect that buddy
all right that's the episode
[Music]
you